we would like to thank the investigation  committee and the academy board of  directors  we appreciate this affirmation by our  colleagues and are humbled and honored  the award is for a head-mounted camera  for producing facial animation  we acknowledge the pioneering work of  olaf shurim  the visionary chris walker and more  recent advances of mr glenn dairy  we thank mr joe letteri and weta digital  for their ceaseless support  and mr james cameron spielberg jackson  and zemeckis  for embracing new methods in production  production work involves long hours we  would like to thank our loved ones for  their sacrifice and support